welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is mazouz today i'm
really excited to be joined by john
lennon who is the managing director of
thrive who are a tech consultancy that
specializes in partnering some of the
most ambitious tech companies
in germany they're on a mission to
disrupt the traditional way of doing
recruitment as they believe it's stale
and outdated
john started his recruitment career in
2011 for a company called optimus search
where he went from consultant to
managing consultant in three and a half
years before taking the leap to start
thrive
john is also a really proud champion of
mental health and recruitment which is
run by rhonda dambrosia which all of you
should know about on this podcast and
john actively shares his personal
journey uh with his own mental health
and is really vulnerable online and
share things that he's really passionate
about which i absolutely love
and thrive recently went through an
exciting rebrand uh they have huge plans
in in the coming years to become the
number one trusted talent partner for
ambitious german tech companies so john
welcome to the podcast
thanks um and hi i'm him obviously um
thanks so much for that brilliant
introduction i definitely could have
said it better myself
no i'm really really looking forward to
this so where we always like to start
is probably a question that you thought
a lot about in your sort of business
owner journey so let's just start with
like what what are your thoughts and
opinions on
what characteristics and traits do you
really believe make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant in in
today's market in the modern day
yeah no it's a really good question and
one that we think about every day really
but i think in this current
market in this moment
i think someone naturally who is
hard-working um i've seen quite a lot of
people who are talented or who are good
salespeople but if they don't have that
kind of work ethic i think that often it
can
not really work out too well um
for me personally i think somebody who
is a good listener um
that that's often overlooked i think in
our industry um we have two
two ears and one mouth for a reason i
think and
um
this kind of stereotype a lot of people
might have when they get into the
industry that they have to be loud and
um have the gift of the of the gab um i
personally think is wrong so i think
when when you listen you learn so much
so that's really important for me and
and i think as well um
being humble and having
humility you know is really important
too because this job you know
nothing can kick you down as much as
this this in the industry i think and
it's important to have that kind of
humble um open mind and willingness to
learn and learn and accept that you're
not necessarily perfect um especially
when you begin but that's part of the
process i think that those those two or
three things are really important
love it
so
just to frame this up for everyone
there's there's quite a few things that
we want to cover here
so just just to give everyone a bit of a
flavor of the things that we want to
make sure we talk about we're going to
talk about a lot of the time your your
journey is as a business owner
but we're going to touch on obviously
you obviously yeah climbing the the
ranks of optimus and obviously you're
really open around your journey with
mental health your stamina adhd so we're
going to make sure that we we talk about
that um and i know obviously yeah that i
i really like how you've executed your
rebrand i think it looks it looks
different and it's fresh um so yeah i
definitely want to talk um to you about
that and what you've experienced what
you've learned to quite quite a few
things so let's i guess let's just start
we don't need to take it all the way to
the beginning but let's just think about
those sort of first three and a half
years of uh working in recruitment
i guess the first thing that would be
great to
to hear from you was just really like
looking back at those sort of first
years first 18 months
in hindsight what were some of the
things that you think you really had to
to to learn or what you learned from
that that period you think what comes up
for you when we look back at that that
part of your career what did you learn
most you think about being a better
recruiter becoming a more high
performing recruiter what did you have
to learn in those early days
yeah um you know those
days earthly days uh 10 years ago now
they they they
they were the most important
uh years of my recruitment career that's
where i learned everything that i know
now and made lots of mistakes and um had
to really dig deeper a lot of the time
um when i got into the industry and you
touched on it already i have a speech
impediment i i have a stutter and when i
got into the industry the last thing i
thought i would ever do was was work in
a phone based outbound sales job
it was my worst nightmare um honestly um
and even still today i think how how has
this happened
but it was something you know i was in a
situation where i had to do well and my
motivation was extremely high because
um i was living on my mom's sofa for the
first you know six months i've come back
from uni didn't didn't know what i
wanted to do i had a german degree and i
was like what what the hell am i going
to do um
and like most people you know he would
listen to this and most people and a lot
of people in the industry they don't
grow up thinking of being a recruiter
you know
they don't dream of being a recruitment
consultant i didn't even know
what it was really um and those first
six months they were you know really so
important there were times most of the
time i you know
didn't like it and didn't enjoy it i was
well out of my comfort zone i
um
you know when you have a candidate who
who drops or uh you have those tough
experiences in the first few months i
think you know what i took from it most
i think was i i learned more about
myself as a person in those in those
first few years like even more so than
anything i learned about being a
recruiter i think i i i became
the person that i am and
before i got into the industry i don't
think i
had a great idea about who i was um
let me just let me ask you something on
that because i i love that thanks for
sharing that i guess so so on that like
what
so the the question that i i sort of
recently asked people that were sort of
like first their first year recruitment
just to give people a bit of an insight
on like that first year journey and
people actually who are in it right now
and the question was just like what what
did you learn about yourself or what did
you get out of recruitment that you
least expected because i'm sure you went
into it going right i'm going to get off
my mum so far i'm going to be earning
money like these things but you just
said there
you find out more about yourself so what
were some of the things that happened to
you personally that you just least
expected
yeah um it was quite a whirlwind i think
you know it was almost like night and
day like the first
weeks the first few months were like so
difficult and
yeah you know i wasn't getting anywhere
until about month five i think and i
think i did my first placement in
in like
yeah in month five and then after i did
the first first one i didn't stop doing
them it was like
night and day something clicked um
but yeah like i i
felt that like if i didn't give this my
best shot then i'm not
you know
going to make myself proud and i think
that was what i learned most as well was
like i am capable of doing these things
that i didn't think i could i am capable
of talking to these high level
ceos or c s
c ctos or um guys and girls who have
been in the industry for years whereas
in your first few weeks you know i i'm
happy to admit i was petrified you know
i yeah i had
one boss on this you know one director
on this side won the director on the
other side of me in it you know i kind
of had to do it you know
otherwise i would have lost my job um
like being forced
kind of but
obviously choosing to do it um and you
learned so much about yourself and i
realized that i had this kind of
resilience that i didn't realize that i
already had
yeah it's amazing yeah like just yeah
what you're saying is you re yeah like
you said you realized
what you were capable of like you may
have doubted yourself and you just you
kept doing more and you kept surprising
yourself and what obviously when you
then realize that it's like okay well
what else can i do what else can i
achieve what else can i put my mind to
right and and do things that i didn't
least expect i think i think that's
amazing mate um
yeah well
let's
so on i want to touch on on the um we're
going to talk about the stamina piece
i want to go through that with you but i
just obviously notice on your linkedin
like you sort of say that on your
linkedin that the first couple of months
you really find on your feet you
struggled then you just had a bit of a
sort of um yeah like you said it sort of
clicked and then you went on to being
like the top performer
for like three years straight so let's
just talk about that because most people
that listen to this podcast will want to
achieve will likely have on their goals
this year or next year that they want to
be the top biller the top performer
whatever
what let's just sort of unpack that a
bit like so you said that you you kept
trying you you kept putting yourself out
there you realize your potential but
what were some of the things that you
really started to get right
um it could be on the bd side it could
be on the candidate side i don't know
looking back what do you think really
enabled you to unlock that potential
to achieve those accolades i'm sure a
lot of people in the office were gunning
for as well
yeah i think the biggest thing for me
was that i was very good at the
candidate side um okay i think it's
again it's like a bit of a myth like a
lot of people come into the industry and
of course you know client clients are
hugely important like you have to have
clients but
i for i found myself to like if i was
candidate led and candidate focused then
the clients would also come and they'd
be happy as well um
you can have all the clients in the
world but if you if if you can't deliver
on that candidate side then
yeah again it's not not not going to
work and i think what i did very well
was where
i i believe that i really understood
what the candidates wanted um so i i
would have really in-depth conversations
with each candidate but i would quickly
know in the first five minutes by asking
a few good questions
what really makes this candidate tick if
this candidate they have all the skills
but if it's not if this opportunity that
i'm trying to offer them isn't right for
them they're never going to take it and
that there's no point trying to put a
square you get a square um it's a round
hole yeah you know um
it's just not going to work and so
that's what i teach for my team now is
you know from the first phone phone
calls like you have to get a really good
idea what the candidate wants what
really makes them tick and it's much
more difficult i think in this day
where yeah in our tech market the
candidates have so much choice but yeah
i think it was my my focus on the
candidate side and really trying to give
them a genuine service and
understanding where i should put my time
that that is key um
if you have loads of half-hour
conversations with can candidates that
never really end up anywhere you're not
going to achieve what you want to
achieve by prioritizing okay this
candidate is super invested this
candidate really wants this job and i
can control the situation or influence
that um they should get your time if you
have a candidate who really isn't
invested but maybe the client likes them
or they're really highly skilled like
they still have your time but maybe not
so much so i think time management's
really really crucial um yeah and i
think another thing in hindsight i don't
think i really knew this at the time but
in hindsight one thing that made me
stand out to clients i think was was
that they could trust me um
i'm i wasn't and i'm not your typical
recruiter i
i had a very different approach and i
think i was memorable as well
because of my speech perhaps um because
of the fact that i could speak some some
uh german to my clients as well and i
would just try different things and
i think a big thing especially when
you're beginning beginning in this job
it's so easy to do what everybody else
is doing um yeah it's what makes you
memorable that sticks in someone's mind
you need to get a client to when you
call them to go ah it's john yeah i know
you yeah great or a candidate hey like
it's john i know you you helped me last
time or you gave me some good advice i
think it's being memorable it's really
really really important
yeah love it
so just quickly i'm sure people will
want me to ask this because as you quite
rightly pointed out really difficult
right now candidates are support for
choice so it's crazy right because what
you're talking about
so you'd like to think it makes common
sense right double down on like really
understanding what the candidate wants
and really make sure that you talk to
them about opportunities that are sort
of aligned with that give people the
time the
um committing time to you and like it
just sort of made like why would you not
be doing that but it's crazy right there
obviously there's just been this whole
period of like
transactional recruitment and and you
just decided to go now i'm going to
really double down on these
relationships um and and and clearly
that that's had a real impact on your
performance but what i wanted to ask was
so you know you said around you you got
quite good at
understanding what made them tick
just to get really practical here
because i'm sure people would want me to
ask what are some of your like go-to
questions on that because i think
that might be really helpful for people
particularly right now
um what's your advice around just just
quickly on like actually getting good at
that
which is something clearly that you
pride yourself on yeah i think too many
recruiters will say hey it's john here
from thrive um i've got a brilliant
opportunity for you blah blah it's
rubbish it's crap um
the first thing you need to ask is
what you know what
not even what would your ideal job look
like but when you think of your ideal
job
how does that look
um i'm being very specific in that
quest question as well because it's a
very open question
and then somebody might say something
that challenges me or
um you know progression
but all those things are really surface
level things
but you ask them again you know what
specifically about
progression you know what does
progression mean to you and then you
just say
say again you know why why why why why
and then perhaps even ask it again so
when you say progression is important to
me because of this this and this why why
is that important can you be specific
the more specific you are and of course
you know some candidates might not want
to go into that depth but it's so
important because if you don't know what
they
want
you can't help them truly yeah yeah no i
love that great advice again it's that
commitment to listening you said earlier
on and then as you said that yeah being
intentional around the questions and
don't treat it as a tick box exercise
right john's time is off a progression
tick right on to the next thing right
which as you said we can keep it surface
level so it's just making sure that you
stop yourself of like treating it as a
bit of a tick box exercise and going
okay john
you know you said that this is what you
said around progression tell me a bit
more about that shut up listen
and then again keep probing keep asking
why and then that as you said that can
really help you uncover the actual true
reason or the true motivators and
drivers that then you need to get good
at aligning with the job opportunities
or the the the clients that you work
with yeah and i think the great advice
yeah i'm sorry to interrupt i think that
we as recruiters especially when we
begin and it's very notable to run
we want things to happen we want to do
that first deal we want to get these
interviews make our clients happy hit
our targets um
but you know it just
we we assume a lot
and i think assumptions are
one thing that we're fried like like
tried tried to deal with very very early
on because just because you think that
facebook is a cool company to work at
doesn't mean that other people do um
just because you assume that this is a
great job or a lot of money or this this
or that that doesn't mean anything
really unless you really know what
someone wants
yeah love that so cool so
keen to go into then you becoming a a
business owner on that journey
let's just talk about your journey uh
with your stamina if that's okay
um
and yeah i've seen a couple of your
videos like i saw your video the other
day talking about it which was brilliant
um and i know that this is obviously
like really important to you so i guess
what i just love to find out it's just a
bit about um your journey with sort of i
guess not letting it um
what's the word i want to say like not
letting it define you but what i mean by
that is like not letting it like hold
you back is what i mean by that because
i just honestly want to say like kudos
to you too like you said being in an
environment where you have to be on the
phone speaking like no doubt every
single day that's something that you
have to
pluck up a lot of career courage to do
um compared to maybe some people that
obviously don't have to deal with that
and i think
yeah i just want to really just say
kudos to that because i know growing up
like how old are you john
32
yeah so i'm 28 right so we were sort of
on that cusp of like social media and
stuff that was growing up but like
school is a [ __ ] horrible place mate
like i think like a stamina stuff like i
remember we had a friend right and i'm
just being completely honest we had a fr
and i got my fair stuff as well my name
is
i'm a white guy i was brought up muslim
so i i there's all the things that make
you who you are is what people pick on
right so i remember we had a friend
called dexter who had a stammer and we
literally used to call him did at the
decks that's literally what we used to
do right
so i i know there would be so many sort
of highs and lows of this but like i
guess would you mind just sharing like
for anyone that might be listening that
might be on the journey or these things
like how
how have you gone about like i said not
letting it define you and hold you back
like what's been your journey with it
for anyone listening that might be on a
similar journey of something else that
could relate
yeah
i mean it does it is a very central part
of my character but i remember like
i was i was fortunate i when i was 16 i
went to like an intensive speech therapy
course um up until that point i i really
really couldn't talk much at all because
yeah i because i i chose not to almost
because it was it was too embarrassing
or
their embarrassment yeah like the
anxiety was like huge and yeah in the
same way and it's not the kids everyone
has taken the piss it's horrible man
it's cool i can imagine yeah but
like as an adult obviously like that
happens and that that happens in
school but now i think you know for me
like i
it's so important but it's important in
a good way because if i didn't have
as
stutter if i didn't have the experiences
that i've had and i wouldn't be who i am
and i think that one part of myself um
like as a person and as a recruiter and
a business owner that i'm proud of is
that i'm quite
i'm humble um and yeah and that comes
from
the experiences that i've had and
you know getting getting called to john
is is not very nice and um
going into
going into a coffee shop you know now
and still still you know i find it
difficult um
to say yeah i have this please um and
you get looks in this but
it doesn't really
matter really because i think it it
everybody has their own thing or things
and
i truly believe that it's made me who i
am and i think that i didn't know that
when i was younger i hated it i don't
i hated you know i would give anything
to not have this anything to fit in
that's what you do when you're younger
you do anything you'd want those things
taken away yeah
and i think the recruitment gave me the
confidence with my speech as well
because again it was like
on day one you know here's the phone and
call up this guy like and i'm like
yeah
like
what am i gonna do um but doing it and
doing it and i i got some abuse on the
phones as well like i i remember one
time
um
a candidate sent an email to my boss
saying like how can you have this guy on
the phone
it's a disgrace um he you know look like
you can't understand him
and that that
you know hurts obviously but also
it fires something in in me like i like
three people wrong i like being the
underdog and i think that
that's a really like strong kind of
asset to have but you know it it
it shaped me profoundly but i think in a
good way and i wouldn't change it for
anything um yeah and yeah i think that
that
that hardship is is a profound thing in
our industry as well because it requires
resilience in our job and i think that
it's only done good things for me and
again you know
some of the clients that i i had you
know i'm fairly sure they they came back
to me or they liked me just because i
was different um yeah so yeah it's a
very interesting
one yeah yeah i mean there's loads of
there's loads i'd love to talk to you
about it i guess
i guess the only thing i'll just be
interested to get your take on because
you're right it's just really weird this
this sort of journey right where
as you're younger you do anything to fit
in
and then as you get older
not all the time but this is definitely
how i've found it seems like you have as
well as like but as you get older the
actual things that make you different
are the things you're actually most
proudest about yeah i mean and they're
the exact things that you'd try and like
avoid like you'd avoid when you were
younger because you want to fit in it's
just so weird how it
works out because if i could go and
speak to myself
when i was like yeah like if i was
getting taking the piss out of or
getting picked on for certain things i'd
be like hisham don't hide like don't
hide who you are like own it and like
the quicker other thing it's just the
quicker that you can get comfortable
with owning it and being comfortable
with that rather than looking at as you
looking at something that yeah makes you
different in a negative way is when you
can more quickly look at in the way that
you're looking at it so i guess i just
wanted to ask you that for anyone who's
listening that whatever it may be and
they've maybe looking here as a way of
like
i don't want this or if this is making
me stick out on a bad way and stuff i
don't know what what's been
uh there'll be loads that we could talk
about this but like what's been the
process of you turn like looking in a
positive way do you know what i'm in
because i'm sure that's been a journey
so yeah if there's any advice there for
someone to
yeah like if you could speak to them to
go to that could start going on that
journey yeah and i think um
i think acceptance is huge um yeah
like you can't change change a lot of
things like acceptance is like you
accepting it yourself like this is yeah
i can't change it i'm if that's first
thing accepting yourself yeah yeah you
know like like you can't change it
necessarily or
like it might take a while to change the
situation but i think like being being
optimistic and being hopeful having good
people around you i think is really
really key like having a mentor or being
a being part of a peer network you know
trying to
get rid of negative like influences
around you i think and i think that
especially when people younger like they
need good influences around them um yeah
our industry can be pretty crap for that
i think but i think like a lot of
companies now have this kind of modern
approach to really trying to offer
support but i think you know it's
different for every person and yeah if i
gave an 18 year old me this advice i'd
be like yeah okay cool you know
it's a really tricky one but everyone
finds their feet and i think that if i
was to talk to a kid whoever
started now i'd say
it will be okay it'll be okay this is
really you might not see enough but this
is you and this is a brilliant thing um
and
yeah again like coming back to our
industry this is why our industry is so
brilliant i do believe in its best form
in its purest form it's
i
the word meritocracy is thrown around so
so easy but it is
an industry where young old you know
regardless of your your the religion
color of your skin whatever you
do your background like it is a leveler
and
it you can create kind of your own
destiny part of that career um
but yeah it's a it's an interesting one
but but i think the everyone has did
their own things and i think yeah like
it teaches you a lot
and it's a brilliant thing when you have
to
learn
some things the hard way i think
hardship can be a good thing because
it's where learning happens
yeah no yeah i think yeah it all starts
with acceptance i really love that so
let's segue this then so john john
lennon the the business owner
so i know you've been on a bit of a
journey right so like two years ago you
is it two years you it wasn't two years
ago you rebranded was it when did you
rebrand to thrive well we've rebranded
twice
actually uh okay so uh
2019
yeah it's two years ago so uh we were
previously known as lennon right um yeah
it wasn't really a name that i
i liked um
i've never been like a massive fan of
having your own name and it sounded a
bit like an estate agent or a legal firm
but yeah
so yeah two years ago
we changed from then right to thrive um
and then
uh
last year um in august i hired our
marketing manager jl brilliant fantastic
person and the first thing she said to
me essentially was john do you need to
rebrand again
okay yeah
all right so let's let's break this so
let's just paint a picture for people so
when you started the business you
started with a business partner right
yeah um
it's called london right she's been
going for nearly seven or seven years
now um from the london right thing and
then so that's where you started and
then where where are you now as a
business like how many how many people
are there and those sorts of things
yes so we're still you know relatively
you know small and we're 17 people um
and we are focused you know exclusively
on the german tech market um yeah we
have like a pretty big
for our size kind of back office team
um so we have two people three people
soon in marketing
we have three people
focus on admin and operations um and i
think a lot of people might think i'm a
bit mad for that um but
having that strong support
team enables our sales team to do so
much more so that you know i'm very
happy with that um
this time a year ago we were you know
half the size
um so we've kind of doubled this this
this year in terms of headcount but we
we've got a very ambitious three-year
plan uh to become the number one tech uh
recruiter in germany um
uh be a company of 100 plus
people but more importantly be a company
where people want to work for and stay
and have a career like a
a genuine career where they can
progress um yeah yeah at the moment
that's
where we're at
yeah and i love it great great overview
so
okay cool celeb i'm i'm quite keen to
because i i feel like i know when we
spoke before you feel like in the last
like couple of years you've been on this
sort of bit of a rebirth journey it felt
like yeah like whenever i expect you and
stuff so i guess i i want to sort of
focus on that because there'll be loads
of things in there that you learn
um on that
like in hindsight that i think be really
beneficial for people so yeah obviously
so for how long
again so how long was it obviously
lennon
so when was it that you obviously parted
ways amicably with your business partner
was that two years you said two years
ago i think i'm wrong i think it's three
years ago
okay but yes um so so um myself and a
guy called rob wright uh we he used to
work for gummy callers
and he was a fantastic if he is a
fantastic recruiter uh he was more of a
contract focused guy i was the perm guy
um we thought perfect you know and
you know we did very very well um we got
on well we kind of grew the team out
well um
we made loads of mistakes a lot of
mistakes um
and we did a lot of good things as well
but we were kind of focused on germany
mainly uh but we did bits in the uk
um
and then we decided to to try and
correct the american market um
rob moved over to america and he's
he's settled down there now um and we
had a few people here in london doing it
too um but quite
frankly for me it didn't work um
i could see the effect that the the kind
of having to do later hours was having
on a few members of our team um and i
felt that we weren't really famous for
anything because we were doing america
and germany um but it felt like two very
different comp companies so
me and rob you know
decided as she said um two amicably part
ways um and i made a very conscious
choice to write we are germany this is
all we do yeah this is what we're famous
for really and it's all i know um
and so let's double down and
nail this um
the first thing we did was rebrand
surprise um
and our colors were still blue and
yellow because they were what our colors
were before is learning right um
and it was all good all fantastic uh we
had a decent brand um but essentially we
were still kind of me
um a marketing assistant and like a lot
of sales guys and girls um
you know and i think it wasn't until
that rebrand that things changed
um and things really started to kind of
kick off and the last two years has just
gone like that really
yeah so it's okay cool so that that's
what i'm keen to unpack so
let's just what i'm what i think the
people would be interested to hear
is that firstly
so
because i've asked this a few times and
i think it's just interesting for people
so i think most people if they were to
start a recruitment business
would rather do it with another person
than do it on themselves from the
conversations i've had yeah so
the question i have for you is sort of
is twofold really one
for anyone listening to this that does
have a co-founder
what what advice would you give them to
i guess like give them the best possible
chance of like making sure that they're
both aligned yeah and going in the same
direction because sometimes that can be
a a challenge right yes and then two
like how did you make sure that you it
did end
amicably because it doesn't always
yeah is what i wanted to ask you so how
did you make sure you were both aligned
yeah and then how did you make sure like
yeah you just didn't it didn't go sour
yeah so um myself and rob we weren't you
know
best best best mates but we were like
acquaintances of
some common friends and so we knew each
other quite well and that was a really
good base basis
for the future um we didn't have any
kind of you know signed um agreement
that says you know if this happens this
happens and you know if this goes wrong
this happens so that would be one thing
that i'd recommend with some things
written down have that in place before
you even begin um because that solves a
lot of issues further down the line um
but i think you know in hindsight again
like it's about being being open um
being like really transparent with each
other i i couldn't and i wouldn't i
don't think have set up um
thrive
on my own i don't know if i
if i
had that like push at the time to want
to do that um and having the support of
of rob was instrumental um
but i think you know just over time it
just changes and that and that's fine
too um when it came down to to you know
the like buyout essentially you know i
think we were both on a really similar
page um
so it wasn't acrimonious in any way
really and like we're in contact when we
chat still and you know it's all good um
we wanted different things and that's
normal and that's fine um
but yeah like
if there's anyone you know who's
thinking about setting up a business or
um i think a lot of it is it's not as
easy as as you might think it is um when
i
got into the in uh
when i got to setting up the company
like if you always think you know i can
do this better than my boss and i see
this a million ways um but it's i think
having a good network and support is
really really crucial and that's where
having a co-founder can be really
helpful because
it can be tough you know
okay
nice so let's just let's just go into
the last two years then because clearly
yeah like you said like you you've
this this is where the real sort of um i
don't want to just discount all those
early years
of course but i guess to be fair on that
you said
just to make sure we do touch on it so
you said you made a lot of mistakes like
what would you say was some of the
biggest mistakes you made
uh
yes i kind of see the first four years
almost was like that was our mistake
phase i mean obviously okay
now but
i guess the biggest one was like uh we
hired some good friends of ours um okay
and that just doesn't work it just
doesn't work at all um yeah we thought
we were being really clever that
it had to be rob's best mate and my best
mate too but rob would manage my best
mate and i would manage his best and
he'd be fine
um and it was fine for about a year you
know really making a lot of money doing
very well everyone happy and then it
just
it just like imploded and it was a you
know as a serious time where
um
you know like the relationships with
those guys aren't the same anymore um so
i think you know one key rule is you
know don't don't go into business with
um friends i think um
don't just i lose your mates yeah yeah
it didn't work for us um
yeah and and yeah like i think also like
we were trying to be too broad we were
trying to do little bits here and there
because obviously in your first few
years it's tough
cash flow finances etcetera you want to
say yes
anywhere um yeah and i think if i could
go back in time
i would have chosen for us to do one
thing very very very well um and another
thing as well is the
marketing branding
in my opinion is absolutely crucial and
i would hire you know an internal
marketing
manager and even an operations or kind
of administrative assistant too because
what i know now is that having that
support and that expertise would have
been a game-changing in the early days
where no one knows who you are
you're you know like like you can't
approach your old clients all this stuff
no one knows who you are your website
costs 100 quid off of wix or something
and you know like that the brand i think
is key
really yeah no yeah
thanks for being honest so
let's just talk about because it was one
of the early things that you said
so talk talk to us about like
what so before as you said you're doing
a bit
here doing a few bits in america uk all
of that
so talk to us about what
why would you say to someone listen to
this
like they should really make sure that
because you hear all the time now like
having a niche right yeah and i'm just
always too interested to hear from
people like what what and what being
niche means to them so like when you
rebranded and it's thriving like right
we're just going to do germany but how
did you break that down for it to be so
obviously germany that's part of the
niche because you're only doing one
location but then how did you like like
how have you now like made it even more
niche if you have like how does it now
work yeah so yeah like again i'm saying
kind of meeting these niche but at the
same time like when you're a smaller
company i think like
like you have to
you know look at other opportunities as
well so our niche really is german tech
but that in itself is huge um yeah so we
have broken it down into what we call
critical and emerging tech but really
that's that is broad um
so you know like what we're trying to do
is a balancing act and but like as we
grow
the intention is it's become much more
kind of niche but
i think
there's a big opportunity there for for
for companies to
yeah if you're known for one thing only
and even if that thing is relatively
broad if you're known for one thing only
that can only
be good because you are known as the
experts people start to hear about you
if you're a jack of all trades and you
do little bits of your
your
impact on that market is so so so small
and because you're spread so so far but
yeah for us you know germany tech
is very broad but it's also quite niche
and
over the last two years especially we
have seen the impacts of that um by so
many clients candidates um you know
people coming to us which didn't really
happen in the first few years because
we weren't famous for anything so things
about being famous
yeah
and then so just because i think people
be interested so how so you've got
critical tech emerging tech yeah all in
germany
how do you then break it down do you
then have people doing like particular
roles you have people doing i don't know
how do you then break it down a bit more
or how or do you yeah so we we kind of
break it down based on location so
um in our team it's it's kind of mainly
berlin munich and hamburg north rhine um
best violin um so it's more like
location based and then within those
teams there are people who are more
focused on say on front end software
development back-end or data
um yeah yeah yeah okay so let's because
i have to ask i wanted to make sure we
asked this and then we'll carry on the
sort of business journey
um
where
like i i definitely see this like people
um
are really conscious of like making sure
that they that in terms of their
portfolio as a recruitment business is a
diversifier so it's not just all in uk
they might want to have a team in uk
germany america right which makes sense
why you're obviously trying to do
different things
so um
so i think most people would say the uk
market is so
[ __ ] saturated yeah and you might
even start to say the same for germany
now because i i do see more recruitment
companies that only do germany or i only
do netherlands etc
so i mean you don't have to give all of
your secrets away but just just curious
like what the people like if i was a uk
recruit right now and i might be
speaking to you and i've never done the
german market before but i've done the
uk market like what things would you say
don't do this he should or like avoid
doing this like where do people go wrong
when trying to take their recruitment
skills or try and build their
recruitment desk in a german market
after maybe working in the uk market
what are the nuances that
yeah they had to learn the hard way
they they
don't don't try and be a british
recruiter i think like um
it's it's there's like so many nuances
and i think i i have an advantage
because i i did german and i lived in
australia and all this but like
too many people like they think it will
work you know that's what we've found
out in america as well it's like we
had to learn the hard way that you can't
necessarily apply the british way of
doing things today because it's a
different culture um
similar similarly in germany or
netherlands or anywhere um like you have
to tweak things and obviously like the
british recruitment
industry is very well regarded as being
the the kind of you know the number one
best best
quality best results yeah like you have
to adapt to that local culture and it's
just even very very small things like
if you're talking to a candidate who's
from another country or a client from
another country don't use english
phrases that they won't understand you
know if you say yeah oh it's a game of
two halves or you know like that they
don't understand it so
i think it's about talking a lot more
slowly as well and just trying to kind
of kind of immerse yourself in that
culture so
whether that is trying to read the
in english um but like you know read
like local news just knowing about that
country well you have to visit it and
you have to try and understand it
because it is different like you can't
apply the same things i don't think yeah
um and you'll see most people do
business in english right
yeah in german yeah yeah like yeah i'm
i'm one of the very very you know like
well i'm the only person at the moment i
mean our company who who speaks like any
level of german and i must say that my
german isn't
particularly good at the moment so
yeah
i love that fair enough yeah so yeah you
just got to commit to immerse yourself
in that culture and i guess just don't
be ignorant right and just yeah be yeah
like be mindful of the things that
you're saying and yeah you might have to
learn some of those things the hard way
yeah yeah
yeah so cool so let's just talk about
the last sort of 12 18 months as we come
towards the end here
so
you've invested a lot in yeah marketing
um operation uh admin assistant piece
what what else
would you say have been like clearly you
must have gone down the journey of
lighting making sure like you've got the
best possible tech stack that you feel
enables you and your team to perform
well like what are some of the the tools
that you've invested in over the last 18
24 months that you feel like you just
couldn't live without now
yeah and i'm alright
to obviously say names and stuff yeah um
yeah of course yeah yeah i mean the most
important
thing that a recruiter or recruitment
company can invest in is a good
crm um we use vincere we moved over from
ventura about two years ago um and it's
been
probably the best investment you know
piece of kit that we've made um and this
is coming from somebody who as a
recruiter i was terrible at using
database i was shocking um because i was
making deals and money like i thought i
don't need to input this i don't need to
code this up i was lazy essentially um
but like as a recruiter if you really
get to know your system well it can it
can double triple the amount of money
that you make because it works for you
so yeah
and
venturi has been a huge one for us um
about a year ago we
started to move over towards like trello
for time management and for planning
your days and weeks and the consultants
and have handled that extremely well so
we use that
not just for like you know tracking
candidates or
um
you know making day plans but we also
use it kind of um company-wide to like
kind of keep everyone in the loop
between the marketing operations and the
sales teams and
myself as well um
we
during the kind of first year of the
pandemic you know like most people we uh
moved over to like teams
i'm not big fan of teams um
i've it just it just like killed my it
killed our computers essentially so we
we moved over to um
to
slack which is a difficult word for me
today um but that's only now that that
is brilliant it it really has been a
game changer um a for like internal
collaboration so if we're now it's
better than whatsapp isn't it it's like
you don't then i don't have to be
speaking to my like mum or dad and then
i get a work text that separates it
yeah
and it's awesome because the team can
collaborate better as well there are
various channels for different things
going on um
so they're like some really really small
things that were very impactful as well
um we use you know source breaker which
is great too although i do still think
that
um every recruiter should know the
fundamentals of like kabulian search i
think you need to know that um
and yeah you know i think for me as well
like kind of using google sheets and
um as spreadsheets and docs has also
like been a bit of a game game changer
for me as well and um
calendly as well as wickets because um
i have adhd and my time management isn't
the best so actually having somebody
book into me
is [ __ ] amazing yeah yeah i love that
yeah mate yeah i love i love it
obviously clearly you've been on a bit
of a journey on it there he said some
really good good interesting tools there
um so talk talk to me about i i wanna
obviously before we finish i wanna touch
on like the full day working week and
what you what you've noticed so far
because i know you've recently
implemented that
but like so as you said like you've
really grown in the last 12 yeah like 18
months like what would you put that down
to out of interest like what are some of
the key parts of that recipe that you
think you've really got right that has
enabled you to yeah take the the
business to to where the best place it
has been in the world yeah i think the
covid
the whole pandemic you know it was a bit
difficult for
individuals and businesses everywhere
but for us
it it made us it made us because we took
a very kind of big
i suppose risky decision back in march
2020 where we didn't put anybody on
furlough we didn't make anybody
redundant
we decided as a team you know as well
that we were just going to like fight it
um so we kept our marketing
function when like a lot of our
competitors didn't
i got rid of that we had a sales team
who were you know they weren't calling
that client saying hey give us your jobs
because there weren't any jobs um but
they were calling up and with a
long-term
uh kind of mindset so you know we're
here if you need anything um let's catch
up again you know in three months time
like it was like a long term game that
we played and we were giving like
genuine value to our clients
so our team
particularly our sales team
they worked
their asses off tirelessly during the
really hard hard months march april may
june you know those months were really
[ __ ] hard um where they're working in
their bedroom or
you know in in the kitchen with their
little brothers and sisters running
about and stuff and
um they worked their asses off in really
really tough times and i think that made
them as well um yeah if they can work
through that and push through that
and
we obviously you know supported them as
much as we we could and wanted you know
kind of felt that we needed to um
but
when the market started to pick up again
we were just starting to smash it
because we
learned so much and grafted so much and
also because we had that long-term game
clients were coming to us now saying hey
you really helped us back in april
because you gave us some great advice we
hosted
i think five or six webinars as well
which were like you know how to find a
job in this market how to find
candidates how to bounce back from the
you know so we kind of took a very very
educated um risk in terms of doing it
but we hired someone in april in may
um and we we kind of decided to go
against it and it worked
and then talk to us about well i guess
what what's what's been
have you have you got any better at
hiring for your own company yet
[ __ ] light
yeah i mean because that's always a real
real i mean yeah like what have you come
to grips with like what like what isn't
absolutely non-negotiable for you guys i
don't know
yeah how have you got better at the
hiring piece yeah again made all the
mistakes there um and i think it's i
always find it amusing how crap
recruitment companies are hiring for
their own team um but i think you know
it's a tough job to hire for because
there isn't a type
um
of person so like you have to be really
forensic in your in interview process
our interview process now is pretty
um defined and non-negotiable in terms
of what we asked and if we lose people
to that but it's fine um how many stages
is that
it's like it's like a free stage
essentially um but it would be like a
very short telephone uh chat with me um
just to find out more about thrive and
us to find out about them and then they
would talk to one of our sales managers
for 30 minutes and then we would invite
them into the office so yeah it can move
very very quick but again
you know
it can be a bit slow um but that's fine
but that's fine for us um but
non-negotiables for us you know we are
very strong now in terms of what we
know who we are
um and therefore we know what kind of
people we want to attract and so our
values are really important and stay
true to that the biggest thing for us
you know is
empathy it really is um we don't want
any [ __ ] in our team um yeah
someone could come in and say
i promise you know i've his his my bid
for billings of a million pounds last
last last last year but if you're a bit
of an [ __ ] like
yeah that's because every single person
in our business is so important to us
especially at this stage the
one person who doesn't align to those
values will bring everything down so
it's really important for us like
empathy is huge because it it not only
helps collaboration in the team but it
creates a really nice environment and a
collaborative
competitive environment too but not
competitive in a in the traditional way
the last right
then i think also finally like respect
because
we're not
you know like we're not like like a
virtuous fluffy company but like like
we're not doing the four day week
because
uh we're like super nice people or like
like we don't want to have empathic
people because we're
super nice it's respect is important too
so like risk respect for the company and
the process that we have and the way
that we do things but also with respect
to each other and respect to yourself as
well so
that's super important to us
those kind of two or three things there
yeah and i think it's really really
important right now that you really stay
true to those
values and what's important i spoke to a
recruitment owner this morning we're
just talking about like like we said
before like it's so difficult right now
like i'm sure you could look at the
amount of job opportunities you have and
it could be quite easy for you to sit in
front of someone and go
yeah they could probably come in they're
not not quite right what we normally go
for but let's get them in like we need
help otherwise it'd be quite easy to
drop those standards yeah and then this
guy just openly said to me like we we
dropped those standards on free people
we knew we were but we were busy
and the other people they ended up
letting go because because they they
weren't right right yeah and that that
will always that's what i sent him like
if you really know what your standards
are and you hold those to even now even
how busy it is and you know you've got
opportunities that they can make you
money for
like it will work itself out won't it
that if you really stay true to that
it's just about working out knowing what
those things are and then staying true
to it even though
it may take a bit more time right you're
going to grow more quickly
but you're going to grow more quickly if
you take it more slow if you get what i
mean rather than trying to grow really
quickly higher really quickly and then
you get quite a few of them wrong you
know it's so tempting it's so tempting
but you know like we've had experiences
too in the last few weeks even where we
like do we don't and but it's about
being like really strong
to what you believe in and i've had some
of my managers say come on man we need
to hide this person it's like no you
know
yeah
it will work itself out it'll work
itself out yeah yeah
so before we finish then let's like
biggest biggest challenge so far in the
four-day working week
biggest like
i guess maybe insight um from it so far
and then final thing is biggest surprise
so far since doing it those three things
and we'll wrap up there so firstly
biggest challenge so far on the four-day
working week biggest challenge so it's
early days you know we're in week five
now um it's early days still but the
biggest challenge so far was to convince
some of our team members that this was a
good thing to do um a lot of them for we
don't even have enough time in five days
how the [ __ ] are we gonna do it in four
um so that was a big like obstacle to
overcome at first um in the first few
weeks you know there was there was you
know more stress i guess and pressure
because it was very new to the guys and
to me um
but
you know i've over the last couple of
weeks like that has no subs noticeably
increased i mean improved um but what
was this
the biggest like learning or insight
that you've sort of taken so far um
there is uh you know i'm even more
convinced now that is the best thing to
do um
you know obviously before we did it we
did lots of
research spoke to a lot of people and i
knew it was a good idea a good theory
but obviously
there's some doubts in your head is it
is it going to work but the biggest
thing i've learned is that if you trust
your team
they would do spectacular things so it's
you know we have
we're in a very very good good place and
i think it's for sure the right thing to
have done for us
and then biggest surprise so far
um biggest surprise um biggest surprise
was that actually a lot of the guys
aren't
finding the temptation to do work on a
friday um
because our team
by most companies you know they're super
ambitious committed
motivated and i thought
i really don't want him to do this but i
bet he or she
yeah but they're nice and that's great
and so the best things have happened you
know they
wanted
just just to round up on this because i
think it's really nice that's right my
biggest source of happiness from this
four day week is that one of our guys is
able to go to
gym
gym on a friday um which he was never
able to do he wasn't able to go to
moscow on friday and he's been doing
this and it's so so happy from it and so
you know that ties into the whole reason
today if our team are healthier happier
more productive in those days then
everyone's going to benefit from that
i love that
john been an absolute pleasure thank you
for being nothing but yourself honest
um yeah really excited to to see where
you guys are in the next like two three
years
and be a kudos to you mate on on
building out the career that you have
despite you may be thinking when you
were younger the the things that you
wouldn't be able to do
um so yeah honestly mate uh it's been a
real pleasure i know that you you'd be
more than happy if people want to reach
out on a thing around maybe
a week or two things on linkedin yeah
and see john thank you so much for
coming on the podcast mate thanks so
much for having me man